et la façon des passes et de faire de la
petite politique
l'ibpt aux jeunes et à de l'énergie à
revendre son image de renouveau et ses
promesses de changement au td justin
trudeau à ravir le leadership du parti
libéral et a dominé les sondages pendant
les deux ans qui ont suivi
mais cela ne suffit plus il surfait sur
une popularité qui est un peu
superficielle pendant longtemps il y
avait le droit de le faire mais là
depuis qu'ils essaient de montrer qu'il
est sérieux il n'a pas plus à 6h depuis
huit mois les libéraux baisse dans les
intentions de vote
passant du premier au troisième rang
pendant que les néo-démocrates
empruntait le chemin inverse
au québec seulement 17 % des électeurs
jugent que justin trudeau serait le
meilleur premier ministre thomas mulcair
est deux fois plus populaire
lorsque tu as un thomas mulcair qui
jadis était chef d'alliance québec qui
était un des anglais à québec mais qui
est rendue plus catholique que le pape
sur les questions québécoise depuis un
bout de temps
c'est très difficile pour un trou d'eau
et scrat yanis comme justin trudeau de
se positionner sur des questions
nationalistes parti libéral sur le
terrain les candidats sont déjà en
campagne
mais ici dans le comté donne ses
quartiers villes les libéraux se battent
encore entre eux pour l'investiture du
parti
sept personnes s'affrontent dont
l'ancienne candidate à la mairie de
montréal
mélanie joly s'est lancé dans la course
tardivement en février moi je fais les
choses différement dans la mesure où je
m'implique dans une investiture alors
que plusieurs candidats n'auraient
peut-être pas fait ce choix là elle m'a
donné des noms de la scène que je vais
rappliquent
mais mélanie joly et le parti libéral
n'avait pas le choix imposé une
candidate aux militants de hand sic
aurait pu provoquer une révolte et une
désertion des membres
ils ont tenu du carlo qui est lieutenant
dans les forces armées fait campagne
pour devenir candidat libéral depuis
deux ans je me suis lancé la campagne
même temps que madame joly a lancé sa
campagne municipale jusqu'à pour moi
c'est pas un plan b au plan c'est
l'assemblée pour le choix du candidat
qui était attendu à l'hiver puis au
printemps et maintenant retardé en août
ou septembre intéresse cela permet à la
dernière venue de rattraper son retard
dans la vente de carte de membre est ce
que vous auriez souhaité une investiture
plutôt oui je le cacherai pas le plus de
temps qu'on a comme candidat officiel
l'été c'est un temps magnifique à
montréal mais surtout un indicative il
on a des activités partout le fait de
jouer ce jeu-là de retarder d
investiture justement parce que son
candidat n'est pas prêt ça va mal avec
c'est donc l'idée qu'ils voulaient
prouve pouvoir c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui ne jouerait pas la politique à
l'ancienne
là on entre dans un dans une histoire de
double visage
si vous êtes prêts pour ce changement là
c'est vrai changement nous réussirons
l'avocate rachel bendayan va tenter de
reprendre pour les libérons le comté
d'outremont que thomas mulcair
représente depuis huit ans les québécois
commencent à comprendre notre plan pour
la classe moyenne et ils sont très
contents de voir qu'ils vont avoir un
baisses d'impôt de 7 pour ça que on va
envoyer des chèques à tous les mois aux
familles avec des jeunes enfants
nous allons réduire le taux d'imposition
de la classe moyenne
promettre des baisses d'impôts et des
chèques aux familles
ce n'est pas très différent comme façon
de faire de la politique là où justin
trudeau à innover c'est en expulsant les
sénateurs libéraux du caucus et en
écartant les candidats qui sont contre
l'avortement des choix courageux bien
accueilli mais l'appui des libéraux à la
loi c 51 sur les mesures anti
terroristes qui pourraient compromettre
certaine liberté a été très mal reçus
comme libérale c'est important de
liberté de nos droits nos libertés et
anthony
quant à investir pour les parties
liberati car anthony di carlo comme
d'autres candidats se fait rabrouer par
des militants qui s'inquiète des
nouveaux pouvoirs de surveillance
accordés aux policiers et aux services
de renseignement qui a beau dire qui
soutient le canada de pierre trudeau et
de la charte des droits et libertés que
lorsque vient le temps décidé de
trancher
ils n'osent pas les défendre parce qu'il
parle pas parce qu'ils jouent une joute
politique et de positionnement pour cet
analyste le produit histoire fait ce
doublement sur justin trudeau
il doit aussi renverser une tendance
lourde depuis 15 ans la désaffection des
canadiens pour le parti libéral
les libéraux ont perdu 80% des débuts
dès qu'ils avaient lorsque jean chrétien
était toujours pas mené ce week-end là
ils ont perdu quatre députés sur 5,4
élections successives ils ont perdu des
députés c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut effacer du jour au lendemain grâce
au fait que le fils de l'autre est
devenu chef du parti libéral
les militants libéraux croient que
justin trudeau peu remonté la pente que
lui conseille-t-il pour sa campagne au
québec continuer à sortir des politiques
cette semaine avec ses 32 points en
démocratie de se concentrer sur le
contenu puis d'oublier qu'est ce qui
pourrait se passer dans les sondages
aucune affiche équipe soit sur le
terrain paris aux gens c'est juste
continuer à travailler travailler fort
d'être plus visible ici au québec
pas seulement des événements mais aussi
d'un email
1 les gens il va l'écouter lui le chef
parle et où ce trou d'eau sa vision il
était bébé quoi surtout et jusqu'à
besoin de démontrer sa plus